Napoleon Dynamite of the world by storm
for what seemed like years an entire
generation couldn't stop making jokes
about ligers llamas and sweet skills but
what's become of Jon Heder the man who
wore the iconic vote for Pedro t-shirt a
lot as it turns out throughout much of
his career he has been known to get
positively weird he's appeared in all
manner of bizarre web productions side
projects and short films from Robot
Chicken to Buddy Holly is alive and well
on Ganymede his range of expression and
delivery has added the perfect touch of
surrealism to many productions but there
was no work that more encapsulates his
facet of his filmography than sock baby
a four-part action comedy series soccer
baby is a Lucinda Tori spoof of
everything from blaxploitation to
classic sci-fi it's the kind of thing
you get introduced to in college and
then quote obsessively for years
afterward EDA plays the leader of the
dastardly frog man who promptly gives
birth to his own doppelganger in real
life Heder as a kind-hearted family man
but on screen he's far from afraid of
the truly bizarre it's not all glitz
glamour and weird online comedy for
Heder he seems to mostly love his life
as a typical family man more than
anything else he married fellow Brigham
Young University alumnus Kirsten bales
in 2002 and they're raising four
children together in their California
home Peters Instagram features plenty of
highlights of fatherly joy from helping
out with Halloween costumes to petting
llamas to the heat of family getting the
Nintendo one though he turrets work
steadily for years now and shows no
signs of stopping it's clear that his
home life is very much the Sun around
which he orbits he lives a quiet life by
Hollywood standards and it seems to suit
him just fine though his career has
extended far beyond a vote for Pedro
t-shirts and jokes about skills heater
isn't averse to revisiting a signature
performance on screen he reprised the
role of Napoleon in a Robot Chicken
sketch and recorded a number of
commercials of Pedro himself ef'n
Ramirez to promote the 2005 Utah State
Fair you see flipping sasquatches around
here Plus in 2014
heeda played the part of napoleon
bonaparte Steen aged Mutant Ninja
Turtles this is to say nothing of the
many interviews in which in the middle
of promoting something entirely
different he's asked to reform a famous
line he
polian did you wet the bed last night
hey dawn did you take a dump in your bed
last night that uh that was perfect
happily Heda takes it all in stride and
he's never lost any gratitude for his
iconic role in 2018 he told The Herald
Tribune parents are introducing it to
their kids friends are introducing it to
their younger friends 14 years since it
came out I think it will always relate
to youth culture and the awkwardness of
being young and being on your own
without any responsibility in the years
since the Poli and dynamite Peter has
been presented with plenty of
opportunities he keeps the details to
himself for the most part but it's clear
that he's turned down more than a few
chances to be part of some projects that
ended up going the distance while some
might see this as foolish heeda
considers it an asset because of his
early work he can pick and choose
exactly what kind of work he wants to do
and figure out a work-life balance few
actors get to have in 2012 he told
vulture I realized how happy I am trying
to be somewhat normal without becoming
huge and not so much normal but grounded
down-to-earth he also compared his work
to that of his father a family doctor
the two professions may appear quite
different but he does always wanted the
same level of community and quiets in
his life this allows him the option of
saying no to projects he finds
distasteful like raunchy comedies though
he's not strayed too far from his comedy
roots Heder does dip a toe into the
world of dramatic film now and then
especially the independent ones in
recent years he's appeared in the
relationship drama weep away for now the
Walt Disney biopic Walt before Mickey
and for Ellen a downbeat story of
divorce and creative failure
he has been fairly tight-lipped about
the stage of his career perhaps as an
experiment he's still waiting to see the
results of or a new direction entirely
regardless it's a pleasure to see him do
his thing as an actor especially when
he's pushed to take his skills the new
emotional places beyond he does role in
one of the biggest sleeper hits of the
21st century and has continued passion
for the performing arts one of the most
important parts of his life is his
foundation in the Mormon Church his
entire life has been shaped by his faith
from his time at Brigham Young
University to his choosiness when it
comes to what projects he's part of when
a star the effects of his upbringing on
his career he told vulture these are the
standards I live by and whatever comes
my way in the future whether filmmaking
or anime
or whatever I'm going to do my best to
live by those standards regardless of
fame fortune or Fairweather friends HIDA
will always have those grounding
principles to guide him if the future is
like the past they should take him far
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]